بالنسبة لأندريه ، كان هذا أصعب الوداع
الذي أحبك ، فهو يقول لبناته وهو
يستعد للسباحة من أجل حياته أن
يغادر الأب ، يسأل أحدهم نعم يجيب
الطبيب الشاب من جنوب بيلاروسيا
كان قد دفع عائلته للتو عبر
البلاد من منزلهم بالقرب من
بعد ذلك ، سبح أندريه على الحدود الأوكرانية
في ليتوانيا المجاورة وهو
يهرب من حرب لم تكن له
بالأشعة السينية لبعض الجنود الروس
الذين عالجهم على أنها الحرب.
لقد
أخذت للتو بعض الأدلة لتأكيدها ، فإن ما
أخذته معي يمكن أن
يجعلني مسؤولاً عن اتهاماتي
بالتجسس لدولة الجيش الروسي
بهزائمه وخسائره
تحت حراسة مشددة. هذه الصور هي نافذة نادرة
على الغزو الروسي الكارثي
في ​​فبراير  في اليوم الرابع والعشرين من اليوم الأول من
الحرب ،
نزلت القوات الروسية في هذا المطار
على مشارف
كييف ، وكان القتال الذي أعقب ذلك
هجومًا أوكرانيًا مضادًا
وحشيًا.  إصابات مذهلة في صفوف المظليين الروس ،
جرح العديد منهم في
مستشفى مدينة موزير في جنوب بيلاروسيا ،
نعلم أن معظمهم أصيب بجروح نتيجة انفجار جرح في
الوركين وجروح في منطقة الجذع.
مع الجنود
الذين تعرضوا لقوة نيران غير متوقعة وفوضوية ،
رأوا الكثير من الانفجارات
ولم يتمكنوا حتى من رؤية من أطلق النار
عليهم ، وأخبرنا بعضهم أنهم
مروا بالجحيم ولم يتوقعوا
ما كان ينتظرهم في أوكرانيا.
كانوا يشاركون في تدريبات عسكرية
كانوا غاضبين بشكل أساسي من القائد
الذي خدعهم أكثر من غيرهم بالفعل
استسلم لواقعهم الجديد فقد
إصبعًا أو
ساقًا في الشاحنات التي كانت تنقل الجرحى التي تمت
مشاركتها في ذلك الوقت على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ،
يقول أندريه إنهم وصلوا إلى  ليلة
جلب 30 جنديًا في اليوم الثاني
من الحرب 90 في اليوم الثالث
جاءوا من بوروديانكا بعضهم من
نزل ميل وآخرون من جزار.
تم كتابة رقم على جبين
كل منهم لتوجيههم إلى القسم الصحيح
على الأقل كان لدى الأشخاص الذين تم
قبولهم فرصة جيدة للبقاء على قيد الحياة ،
وكان هناك شخص واحد فقد
فكه السفلي بالكامل وكان
يشكو فقط من تناول الطعام  أو
شربوا أي شيء لمدة ثلاثة أيام ،
لكن الجنود استمروا في الوصول ،
يقول أندريه إن حوالي 40 جرحًا في اليوم في المتوسط
أسهل بالنسبة له لتذكرها
من الأسماء ، على الرغم من أن واحدة على وجه
الخصوص تبرز واحدة من
الروايات الأولى لبداية الحرب
هي الرقم  من القادة الذين
فقدوا على الجانب الروسي العديد منهم انتهى
بهم المطاف في مستشفى مقاطعة موسر ، بما في ذلك
الجنرال سيرجي
نيركوف ، أصيب بصدمة في البطن من انفجار لغم
في تشيرنوبيل ، لذلك عالجناه
وبعد ذلك بعد استقراره تم
نقله مع الضباط الآخرين.
شعرت بالاشمئزاز تجاه هؤلاء الضباط
بشكل رئيسي كان الشعور أنهم كانوا
مجرمي حرب في
الغالب.يقول أندريه إن الرجال كانوا
جنودًا عاديين صغار السن وعديمي الخبرة  18
19 20 عامًا ، الذين كانوا يقضون
يومين في مستشفاه قبل
إعادتهم إلى روسيا ، أنقذوا حياتهم
ولكن تغيرت إلى الأبد ، لذلك
كان لدي انطباع بأن جزءًا صغيرًا فقط
من الجنود الذين تم إرسالهم تمكنوا
من دخول مستشفانا على قيد الحياة
كان لدي شعور بأن بعض الأحياء
المحسود عليهم الذين ماتوا
أندريه يعيدون الآن بناء حياته الخاصة
مع عائلته في مدينة أوروبية
بالقليل الذي يمكنهم إحضاره بشكل أساسي
بالأشعة السينية المخبأة في إحدى
ألعاب ابنته ليتم إحضارها إلى  الأمان والآن
تضيء
ميليسا بلسيانين لندن